the energy union was the focus of a
council meeting on march 5th in Brussels
EU ministers address the main challenges
in the sector and discuss ways to offer
consumer secure sustainable competitive
and affordable energy speaking to
journalists after chairing the meeting
Latvian economy minister Dana rains nice
Isola said ministers outlined their
positions today dear colleagues we
really heard the clear message from my
colleagues that the future energy union
should aim for the right balance between
the several aspects which are actually
the affordable energy which is safe and
secure energy systems which is the
European competitiveness and also
sustainability and the credible pathway
towards a low-carbon economy concerns of
the EU citizens about the energy
security in these difficult geopolitical
times the outcome of the debate will be
forwarded to the President of the
European Council ahead of the march
meeting of EU leaders ministers also
shared views on how to tackle the
development of energy infrastructure the
backbone of the energy Union the debate
focused on how to increase
interconnections in a cross-border
energy market in order to end the energy
isolation of Sir